In the previous lesson we mentioned the term asymptote. And in this past quiz
you saw that the graph of f of x equals 1 over 3x never actually reaches x
equals 0. The y axis. Now if we look at this line on the graph since its
already drawn for us. We can see that it splits the graph. So that the curve
falls down toward negative infinity on one side. And comes back down from
positive infinity on the other side. As I mentioned before, this line, x equals
0, is called a vertical asymptote, for this graph. Here's a graph of the other
function we were looking at before. F of x equals 4 over X minus 1. Based on
this graph, what do you think the vertical asymptote for this function is? Make
sure that what you write is the equation for a vertical line. Since that's what
a vertical asymptote is.